alright guys we finally have a new act
we've got soba nerfs a new battle pass
rgx 2.0 and the game's newest initiator
fade
i've seen your darkest fears
this is the most exciting update we've
seen in months so let's get right into
it
[Music]
all right so back on march 28th our
favorite valerian data miner mike
started sharing info about the game's
newest agent he confirmed that they're
an initiator and even shared some info
regarding their abilities fast forward
to april 15th and mike came in clutch
for us once again he confirmed that the
new agent's name is fade and that rgx
2.0 is releasing with a [ __ ]
butterfly knife then a few days later
riot gave us our first look at her
during the masters broadcast and almost
immediately the entire community showed
just how down bad they are after weeks
of people begging faye to respectfully
step on them she's finally playable so
let's take a look at her kit fade's
signature ability haunt allows you to
throw an orb that reveals enemies caught
in its line of sight a small trail can
be seen on the ground which leads you to
any revealed opponents her q ability
sees throws another orb that explodes
where it lands and keeps enemies briefly
locked within its radius fade's c
ability prowler sends out a cat in a
straight line it locks onto enemies or
trails in its frontal vision cone and
chases them down if you get hit by it
you will become nearsighted you can also
hold down your fire button to manually
steer prowler finally we have our alt
nightfall nightfall sends out a wave of
nightmare energy that goes through walls
and is similar in size to breaches all a
trail will lead you towards any enemies
who are hit by it and they'll also be
deafened and decayed by 75. all of this
sounds pretty crazy but here's scream's
initial reaction to fade
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
alongside the release of fade we're
finally getting some long overdue
souvenirs his shock guards now do 75
damage and his drone only lasts 8
seconds and only pings enemies twice
when you tag them so now double shock
dart kills will be nearly impossible if
your opponent buys full armor and now
that we've got the important stuff that
actually affects the game out of the way
let's move on to what actually matters
the new cosmetics we've got a new battle
pass with some cool new player cards and
skins and honestly these cobra coalition
variants are pretty clean for battle
pass skins hue shift is also pretty nice
but i'm really not too sure how i feel
about the sys skins but if you've been
on twitter in the past week you've
likely seen a million giveaways for the
rgx 2.0 skins they look [ __ ]
incredible
yeah
i'm definitely buying that anyways it's
safe to say that this update might shake
up the meta in a big way fade looks
pretty cool so far but although soba's
pick rate has been on a steady decline
for a while i wouldn't exactly call him
dead just yet that said players have
been pulling off some pretty sick plays
using the intel that fade provides lady
[Laughter]
considering every single initiator has
eventually made their way into pro play
i think it's pretty likely that some
teams will cook up dope executes with
fade that resonate combo is pretty sick
it's too early for me to say if she's
broken or not so we'll just have to wait
and see but for now here's what ethos
had to say about her i don't think she's
necessarily overpowered and i also don't
think she is
like
super fun she's not like a like a like a
reina or like a sky or like a ko you
know or you just like doing flashes for
yourself and just like killing a lot of
people i don't think that definitely a
lot more of a supporting
uh info type of initiator um
kind of somewhere in between the full-on
info that silver provides and like the
full-on like self-sufficiency that like
skye or ko provides i'm kind of sad
because we won't see fade in pro play
for a few weeks but i'm sure some teams
will pick her up in the coming months
i love this next one i'd let fade step
on me you wouldn't let me say that
i tagged this guy on ascent yesterday
and he was like on catwalk and i was
sitting in like near pizza it like
pinged him like three times and i was
able to get the wall bang with like a
bulldog and i was thinking about it i'm
like i don't get this kill next patch
let's move on to what actually matters
the new cosmetics
a little sly smile
new cosmetics